bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau point
de vue point de vue où l'on aime le
débat et la politique
côté politique on est servi aujourd'hui
avec cette grogne qui monte dans le
parti présidentiel
à la veille du congrès de lyon des
marcheurs se rebiffe
on verra si ce mouvement d'humeur peut
faire tache d'huile politique toujours
avec le programme des manuels macron
pour la banlieue un plan que le
président a longuement présenté ce matin
à tourcoing dans le nord un plan de plus
ou un vrai changement dans la proche des
banlieues on verra ce qu'on en pense
ici autour de ce plateau n'hésitez pas à
nous dire vous aussi internautes comment
vous réagissez politique et fiscalité
aussi avec cette bourde à 10 milliards
d'euros
c'est l'addition salée de la taxe sur
les dividendes mais foi de l'inspection
générale des finances personne n'est à
blâmer ni bercy ni l'elysée où un
certain emmanuel macron occupait alors
le poste de secrétaire général adjoint
notamment chargé de l'économie on va en
parler
quant à la poupée barbie s'est-elle de
la politique
en tout cas elle s'affiche désormais
voilé avec derrière son voile sans doute
beaucoup de marketing et peut-être un
peu d'idées au logis bonjour adélaïde
zulfikarpasic bienvenue dans point de
vue vous êtes directrice de bva opinion
et vous allez nous éclairer sur tous ces
sujets politiques à côté de jean-marc
four directeur de la rédaction de france
inter bonjour marc et on attend votre
point de vue bonjour denis craignais où
vous êtes directeur général de la
fondation pour l'innovation politique
professeur à sciences po et vous avez
fait aussi de la politique puisque en
2015 vous étiez candidat les
républicains en languedoc-roussillon
midi-pyrénées
bonjour marc landré bonjour politique
économie sujets de société vous êtes
tout terrain même si votre sport favori
c'est l'économie le football c'est le
football on va parler aussi et vous êtes
rédacteur en chef du service économie
france du figaro alors à quatre jours du
congrès de la république en marche
la grogne monte
la démobilisation gagne une centaine de
marcheurs s'apprête à claquer la porte
en un mot ils dénoncent le manque de
démocratie dans le mouvement
le premier congrès de la république en
marche annonce peut-être un peu morose
votre avis jean marc four ça y est la
république en marche rentrent dans le
rang ça bien parti comme un autre avec
la contestation interne
je crois qu'on confond nouveau et
différent
est ce un parti nouveau oui c'est un
parti nouveau il est né de toute pièce
autour d' emmanuel macron et et a
remporté les élections législatives donc
oui c'est un parti nouveau qui a fait
d'ailleurs émerger de nouvelles
personnalités personnel politique sur la
société civile enfin bon car renouveler
le personnel politique à l'assemblée
c'est indéniable donc nouveau oui
différents non parce que je pense que
mécaniquement de toute façon les
institutions de la vème république font
que vous allez avoir un parti qui dès
l'instant c'est le parti majoritaire a
fortiori en fait il est pilotée depuis
l'elysée dans l'intérêt principal d'un
homme et de sa politique en l'occurrence
emmanuel macron donc je pense qu'on a
qu'on peut être on a confondu nouveau et
différent
ouais c'est un parti nouveau oui
différents n'ont pas nécessairement
dominique reynié un parti piloté de
l'elysée ça c'est normal en effet hui
fin c'est normal c'est le fonctionnement
de cette vie politique
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir que
on est tous d'accord pour observer la
crise des organisations politiques des
organisations collectives les syndicats
ne font pas exception d'ailleurs m6 on
en parle moins on sait que
c'est nécessaire la démocratie mais on
ne trouve pas encore la bonne formule
beaucoup de 60 ans tu es à l'échelle de
l'europe y compris des mouvements qui
s'organise de manière extraordinaire
maritime à partir du numérique par
exemple le mouvement 5 étoiles en
italique et probablement le plus avancé
dans ce domaine mais ça reste un parti
très autoritaire et dirigé par un chef
absolument tyrannique qui beppe grillo
et donc on peut avoir le digital et
l'horizontale en apparence avec un
enfant le chef dictatorial et là ce qui
se passa en marche c'est une crise c'est
une crise comme il avait arrive
désormais dans toutes les organisations
collectives quelle qu'elle soit il ya eu
sable a pas très longtemps qu'on a sur
les premiers grains de sable oui ça ça
veut dire c'est ce qui est dit à
l'instant ça veut dire que c'est un
parti qui quoique nouveau n'échappe pas
aux lois qui aujourd'hui sont les lois
d'airain d'ailleurs dès qu'ils ont été
déjà annoncées en 1913 qui n'échappe pas
aux lois de l'organisation politique est
une organisation discipline et
hiérarchisé de type aristocratique
caporalisation le terme est employé on
va le voir il ya des termes par ses sens
contestataires c'est un peu vrai ça rend
ce que vous disiez surface qui est que
c'est un parti ou un mouvement qui est
piloté d'élise est en revanche très
intéressante par rapport à ce que dit
jean marc four c'est que si on a
confondu nouveau et différent c'est
aussi parce que emmanuel macron la
positionner comme tel avec une espèce de
volonté affirmée de dire ce n'est pas un
parti d'ailleurs ça c'est la mouvance il
est différent même si quand on regarde
les statuts qui ont été déposées au
moment le
mouvement été créé d'ailleurs il ya deux
associations différentes mais rennes qui
s'appelle association pour le
financement du parti dès le départ en
dépit des ambitions affichées la bonne
volonté c'est quand même un parti assez
traditionnel alors effectivement on le
voyait à l'écran on peut le remettre
fonctionnement vertical ce gouvernance
d'élite organisation digne de l'ancien
régime et des vidéos logique
qualificative
rien de nouveau sous le soleil même pour
en marche parce que rappelez vous la
nomination la désignation des candidats
en marche pour les législatives
il y avait exactement les mêmes avocats
blacks étaient utilisés parce que soi
disant qu'il y avait eu un grand
brainstorming d'une commission dirigée
présidée par jean paul delevoye et qui
au final il y avait des gens qui
n'avaient pas été informés qu'ils
n'aient pas été retenues d'autres québec
s'étaient pas présentés qui avait été
désignée enfin c'était une espèce de 2,2
de simulacre alors je le mot état
peut-être après forme de simulacre de
démocratie participative ou de remonter
de la base pour finalement le choix d'un
homme pour un homme et pour une seule
politique
donc au final je suis d'accord avec vous
la nouveauté la différence mais en
vérité on est déjà dans l'ancien monde
de ce qui s'est passé il ya cinq mois
après il faut pas oublier que je marque
pour le disais c'est important pour
oublier que cet abord c'est une
association un marchand notre parti et
le maquereau a gagné la présidentielle
avec une association pas un parti c'est
quand même inédit
il faut quand même le rappeler mais ils
ont fait émerger à l'assemblée
énormément de nouveaux visages
l'assemblée quand même plus proche de la
france réelle qu'elle ne l'était jusque
là on s'est même beaucoup moqué dans les
médias ou autres de la maladresse du
caractère ingénue naïf de ses militants
qui précisément être des débutants donc
nous connaissaient pas tous les codes et
c'était plutôt je dirais réjouissant a
de manière ça correspond aussi à ce
qu'on espérait autrefois enfin un petit
peu avant et donc il ya quand même déjà
cet apport la qui est à mettre au
bénéfice cette nouvelle organisation qui
maintenant rentrer dans le dur qui est
d'arriver j'imagine ça va être grand
rendez-vous dans marche maintenant avoir
des élus aux élections
européenne aux élections locales parce
que c'est ça qui est important sinon ça
n'existe pas un parti de se banaliser
d'avoir des élus vous aidez partout sur
le territoire pour être des réseaux des
relais des points d'appui des points
d'inspiration mais s'il n'y a pas une ag
vers juste pitt se dégonfler de je suis
plus on voit que c'est 350 mille
adhérents
vous allez on paye pas c'est un clic
parce qu'à l'avenir tous les
journalistes qui sont impliqués pour
paresser sur les informations et
adhérents je trouve qu'on ne re dire ça
[Rires]
mais du coup mais ça peut pas se
dégonfler aussi vite que ses montées si
si c'est possible bien sûr c'est
tellement fragile et puis cette ça
arrive un moment où c'est encore une
fois c'est phénoménal de voir il n'y a
pas un pays aujourd'hui démocratique qui
n'est pas confronté à la crise des
organisations politiques c'est
absolument phénoménale grandes
démocraties petite démocratie parti
dominant les petits devenus petits
moyens partie regarder en allemagne et
partout en autriche il n'y a pas d'aidés
le royaume uni ils ont l'air d'avoir
retrouvé de leur force mais n'arrive
même pas à gouverner à faire des
majorités il faut acheter des députés
pour avoir des majorités c'est vraiment
ce qui s'est passé au royaume uni donc
c'est vraiment un phénomène très
passionnant et historique fin d'un cycle
qui a commencé à la fin de 10e siècle en
marche
il ya une forme de renouveau ça a été
dit maintenant il ont pas encore
retrouvé les clés je suis pas sûr qu'ils
arrivent à les trouver
mais cette nomination de
castaner samedi élections désignation ça
peut là aussi quand même ça commence
déjà suscité pas mal de remous
il risque d'être mal élu parce que trop
bien et lui justement moi la question
précédente et c'est aussi une façon de
dire de vous répondre là je dirais oui
et non tiens oui ça peut faire pschitt
dans le sens où il ya bien il ya eu un
tel appel d'air que ça aussi créer un
espoir ni presse qu'une illusion du
c'est l'idée du bottom up à on va la
retrouver d'ailleurs sur les banlieues
un peu style tout ce qui comme des
réseaux sociaux si vous le soudain coûte
fille arrive de la base bar à vin
immergées on a tous avoir droit au
chapitre etc
il ya un moment donné on s'aperçoit que
ce n'est pas le cas donc forcément le
souffle et redescend un peu en même
temps l'objectif précisément de la
convention à lyon et aussi de
s'organiser et il faut bien que
mouvement parti peu importe comment
l'appel
ils s'organisent pour structurer sa
présence politique structuré sa présence
dans les instances locales parce que
province pour l'instant ce n'est pas le
cas donc il faut bien aussi qu'ils
s'organisent un minimum donc de ce point
de vue là je dirais non ça ne va pas
faire pschitt parce que c'est
précisément l'objet c'est de se
structurer en l'occurrence c'est
christophe castaner qui s'est vu confier
par emmanuel macron parce que c'est bien
ça qui s'est passé les rênes de
l'appareil mais il ya bien une volonté
de se structurer pour précisément aussi
ne pas faire pschitt
on va à ce propos écouter françois
rebsamen françois rebsamen maire
socialiste de dijon
il était ce matin l'invité du talk du
figaro il invite vais pas mathieu siro
et on va voir ce qu'il dit sur les
partis moi je pense que les partis
politiques concourent à l'expression du
suffrage donc ils sont indispensables à
la démocratie donc c'est bien d'ailleurs
bien qu'ils votent dans ces parties là
on désigne pas comme ça je crois c'est
mieux de voter d'apprendre à voter et
c'est d'apprendre la démocratie dans les
partis la démocratie n'est pas en marche
c'est le titre de leur tribune mais la
démocratie sera en marche jour où ils
voteront pour élire leur propre état
donc c'est l'exercice de la démocratie
oui c'est les grilles de la démocratie
avec une question centrale puisqu'on
parle d'un parti ou d'un mouvement kino
qui ces structures qui est quand même la
question de son rôle le rôle qu'il se
donne s'il veut se différencier de votre
parti et notamment le rôle qu'il a par
rapport à manuel macron puisqu'un partie
assez traditionnellement ça aussi alors
ça plusieurs rôles dont celui notamment
de sélectionner des candidats de
remporter des élections mais il ya aussi
un rôle fondamental qui est l'animation
du débat public et la question pour la
réplique en marche et comment est ce que
il anime au débat public en étant en
ayant une indépendance par rapport au
président de la république et donc il ya
quand même dans sa structuration qui
effectivement je suis d'accord et
jean-marc force à sa source et c'est les
prémices et le début donc il ya beaucoup
de choses qui sont encore mouvante
cette question est là c'est à ce propos
christophe castaner qui resterait au
gouvernement c'est un problème c'est pas
le chemin vers on voit qu'il sera plus
porte parole mais c'est me resterait
secrétaire
ça me paraît difficile quand même trop
juste par le chef de parti et donc du
gouvernement sont compliquées pour le
parti de critiquer ou de d'orienter le
gouvernement et de son chef et j'ai le
temps au ministre c'est ça semble
compliqué qu'ils offraient icade et puis
c'est et puis tout le travail qui a à
faire en terme d'organisation de
structuration ce serment c'est sans
doute un job à temps plein sur punk puis
l'argument qui consiste à dénoncer le
culte de la personnalité
pardon mais on découvre un peu la lune
enfin d'abord encore une fois sous la
vème république de gaulle mitterrand
sarkozy enfin tout le monde a piloté le
parti majoritaire depuis l'elysée enfin
le chef de l'état l'ont fait avant
emmanuel macron premier point et puis
deuxième point dans le cas particulier
des manuels macron en face ils ont dit
qu'ils accusent de la personnalité mais
on découvre un peu la lune mais c'est un
peu vrai enfin oui au sein d'un public
en marche des rochats de la france aussi
en général il ya un peu de culte de la
personnalité des manuels macro qui en
plus est un président qui lui-même
revendique le fait qu'il veut
centraliser ensemble de décisions qu'ils
veulent et pour lui même et donc voilà
il ya qu hollande qui a dérogé à la
règle
les percus de personnalisation d'après
fo
mais quand même je reviens juste sur le
point le fait que samedi on va élire un
collège un collège vallière christophe
castaner désigné oui sans que ça soit
tous les adhérents mais un certain
nombre d'élus que les ministres qui
votent c'est quelques militants triés
sur volet le volet c'est pas
problématique
ça dépend moi je ce que dit il faudrait
que sa mère est inexact les partis
concourent à l'expression du suffrage
dans le cadre des élections qu'ils
concourent à organiser mais ça ne veut
pas dire qu'un parti qui ne qui n'a pas
d'élections internes n'est pas un parti
démocratique
les organisations ça c'est une espèce si
je sais que ça va contre les idées qu'on
a spontanément aujourd'hui et c'est un
peu dommage parce que c'est une série
d'examens les organisations politiques
comme les partis ne sont pas
nécessairement organisés sur une base
démocratique de démocratie interne ses
bottes c'est pas nécessaire en plus t'as
fait être un parti de démocratique sans
avoir des élections internes c'est quand
il ya des élections internes c'est pas
toujours des élections qui se comportent
qui se déroule de manière saine de
manière transparente enfin il ya eu
beaucoup de cas comme ça qu'ils ont
montré il 12e à droite comme à gauche je
voyais absolument où le ps n'obtient
plus il poursuit ce que dit dominique
vous avez vous allez avoir
on a eu des élections qui étaient très
démocratique des primaires qui était
ouverte en dehors des partis on a vu où
est-ce que ça a conduit les dix partis
je veux dire sir nulle part ou alors
dans des limbes dont elles vont être ça
va être très difficile pour eux de 2,2
de se relever après en l'occurrence que
ce soit un collège haddock ou pas un
collège mouais on a vu beaucoup de
candidats à la présidentielle qui ont
été désignés par un psychologue qui
collège interne dans des parties sans
clé bas l'abba soient consultés bien
avant les primaires et qu'on leur
demande leur part des personnes de tout
trouver à redire par exemple
grand exemple a dit là ce qui est
intéressant ce moment c'est qu'on pose
la question en substance à ce que la
réplique en marché à partir en voie de
normalisation de banalisation
on pourrait renverser un petit peu le
questionnement parce qu'est ce que c'est
pas finalement à la réplique en marche
qui est qu'ils jouent aujourd'hui un peu
le rôle que doivent jouer les parties à
savoir faire émerger des nouvelles têtes
faire émerger de nouvelles idées quand
on voit que les autres partis sont pour
certains assez englués dans leur corps
et dans leur reconstruction c'est assez
intéressant de voir de faire renverser
le prisme et deux devant les choses de
l'autre côté
à ceci près qu'à chaque fois qu'ils
aient d'espèces donnons pas de
raz-de-marée politique mais qu'il ya un
parti qui est balayé du pouvoir
vous avez deux nouvelles têtes nouvelles
idées qui arrive au karibe pouvoir
prenait 93 lorsque le ps a été balayé la
vague bleue il ya énormément de
nouvelles têtes et de nouvelles idées
qui sont apparus quand on a eu le lagoon
la droite qui a été balayée en deux
enfin dans un niveau moins dans 97 c'est
pareil on est toute une génération qui
est arrivé au pouvoir
et avec des nouvelles têtes et de
nouvelles idées donc je pense que c'est
plus le moment avec cette vague que
véritablement la construction d'un parti
nouveau d'un mouvement apple on
l'appelle comme on veut qui fait créé
cette donne là c'est plus le fait qu'il
ya un ras-le-bol et un dégagisme qui
fait qu'on crée de nouvelles choses à
côté alors emmanuel macron toujours
c'était un discours fleuve ce matin sur
la banlieue
un plan marshall ça on connait on l'a
déjà entendu en tout cas le plan que le
président a présenté ce matin n'a
peut-être pas de nom mais il est censé
s'articuler autour de deux idées fortes
l'ordre républicain et l'émancipation ce
sont ses termes des habitants de grandes
idées suivi de grands effets ça c'est
une autre question
on va d'abord écouté emmanuel macron ce
matin il parlait à ce moment-là de lutte
contre la radicalisation dans les
quartiers en l'écoutant citoyens quand
on accepte de la république est
délicieux et démissionner sûr
y compris sur les règles de base de
notre vie ans
c'est pourquoi d'ici au début de l'année
prochaine quinzaine de plan de lutte
contre la radicalisation et d'activation
une politique de déradicalisation seront
non seulement présenté par le ministère
de l'intérieur et l'ensemble des
ministères compétents les dossiers avec
les élus avec des moyens supplémentaires
des fermetures de structures et une
action résolution de terrain dominique
reynié vous a convaincu emmanuel macron
avec une petite remarque préalable
quand tout le passage sur la
déradicalisation est là il n'a jamais
prononcé le mot d'islamistes ça doit il
faire référence je pense pas qu'on crée
de la radicalisation des catholiques
dans les banlieues mais c'est là moi je
on a en a une approche on a une approche
aujourd'hui qui est très marqué par la
suspicion et la suspicion d'impuissance
et c'est malheureusement enseignée par
exactement c'est ça qui est terrible
parce que j'ai pas entendu l'ensemble du
discours j'ai vu des points qui ont été
soulignés par le président il extrait
qu'on veut montrer plein d'intérêt des
choses sont dites qu'ils sont des
vérités et qui n'ont pas toujours été
dit et surtout pas on n'a pas pris la
peine de le dire là ça me paraît très
important c'est pas la même chose de
dénoncer les phénomènes de
radicalisation ailleurs que son côté
solennel lancé il ya un côté il ya un
côté respect je trouve moi moi j'ai
chassé acheteurs un pas que citoyen de
cette façon de parler
là où ça se passe et de dire des choses
qui sont qu'on n'ose pas dire
cantonniers en réalité parce que c'est
ça aussi qui se produit tout le temps
quand on est dans un des quartiers on
n'ose pas trop parler de ça de peur de
froisser et donc on sent bien que
si on a un peu sur le bout de la langue
ou derrière la tête mais ça sort pas
vraiment là au moins c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est dit sur
l'émancipation que vous avez évoquées
c'est un vrai sujet on a tenu ses
quartiers et pardon de le dire comme ça
c'est pour aller vite qu'en dit des
quartiers on n'est pas content de cette
formulation la mérite d'être clair mais
on a tenu ses quartiers dans une espèce
de rapport qui me paraît moins relevée
d'une sorte de post colonialisme d'un
paternalisme insupportable au fond c'est
la logique du guichet vous venez
demander une aide on vouloir croire à
peut-être on verra comment les choses se
passent l'idée de développement
économique c'est ça aussi l'émancipation
à cette question c'est ça la marque vous
êtes d'accord sur le toit dans l'analyse
n'est pas où je suis je suis je suis
d'accord sur le fait qu'il y a le mérite
de faire un descriptif du réel in situ
qui est méritoire encore ce cas les mots
si tu pour dire oui mais plus largement
d'ailleurs parce qu'il n'y a pas que ça
dans son discours un quand quand ils
dînent situe effectivement attention il
ya un problème de radicalisation ça a le
mérite d'être dit in situ quand il y
aussi une situ je veux dire de l'autre
côté une certaine façon il ya comme un
sérieux problème de discrimination à
l'embauché il est temps qu'on s'en
occupe c'est savent aussi le dire in
situ et à certains de choses qui sont
faits comme qui sont dites sur le
terrain au milieu de la population
concernée ça me semble mois positif
en tout cas après on peut pas s'empêcher
de penser effectivement que bon bah oui
à un plan de plus moi je me suis amusé à
compter en venant à 25 ans on en est à
18 ministre de la ville et à 14000 d'une
aide à mort un an 25 ans et on est en un
plan un plan ville tous les trois ans en
gros c'est à peu près ça la moyenne le
dernier c'était après les attentats 2015
c'était s'était parée des oripeaux de la
formule légalité et citoyenneté m'enfin
c'est la même chose
guillaume tabard ce matin dans son
contrepoint figaro rappelé que le
premier c'est olivier guichard en 72 je
crois qu'ils qui commence à parler des
débats au nom des barres d'immeubles
je profite pour donner quelques
réactions nous interne ou alors il ya
jeune mari qui nous dit macron se
pencher sur les problèmes de banlieue
aa je sais pas si j'ai de bon ton mais
sap après ce que ça veut dire
et puis flot du pont la démocratie n'est
plus qu'une illusion quand on constate
que le système et les eaux alors
revient sur le sur la polémique de la
république en marche sur le contre
constate que le système électoral
accepte un taux de 40 %
d'abstentionnistes
c'est un vrai sujet aussi pour en
revenir aux banlieues adélaïde là-dessus
effectivement les plans qui succède et
tout ça une espèce de lassitude de
l'opinion
non je suis pas surpris l'adhésion de
l'opinion en moi j'adore une lassitude
de l'opinion sur le sur lapins où il a
rejoint presque vide sur la
communication
je vais rebondir sur l'ipod votre
internaute quant à 10 microns qui
s'exprime sur les banlieues à ça fait
aussi référence fin sans doute à ce que
l'opinion veut percevoir en termes
d'enjeux pour le président en termes de
postures et des images d'un des riches
quittent le virage social fall côté les
agathois ne le préoccupe des voilà donc
ça peut être perçu comme ça par
l'opinion il a besoin de casser cette
image
or c'est pas forcément que président des
riches c'est aussi le président qui
s'adresse à une certaine partie de la
france
l absence de gagnant voilà ce qu'est pas
et donc ses impôts ça qui fait donc il
faut effectivement au delà de la posture
et de la communication il faut qu'ils
aient un récit derrière est un vrai
objectif donc est-ce que ça va plus ou
pas je peux en mesure de dire mais je
pense que l'opinion c'est plutôt sur ses
ficelles laquelle peut être là c'est
plutôt que sur un plan de plus dans
l'absolu alors question par exemple sur
une des mesures qui est brandi de façon
emblématique ce sont les emplois à vous
devant celle ci on va laisser ses après
celles réalisées par les emplois francs
parce qu on arrête enfin je vais vite
encore m'enfin bon nombre les emplois
aidés sont un peu dans le collimateur de
safran qui ont échoué sous françois
hollande on est d'accord alors là on
nous dit on va les faire autrement il y
aura moins de contraintes donc que cette
fois ça va peut-être marché reste que
qu'est ce que c'est que des emplois
francs c'est quand même
financer l'embauché en cdi ou en cdd de
quelqu'un qui vient de l'un de ces
quartiers défavorisés en nez dans les
entreprises ayant un droit
voilà donc cesser pardonnez-moi
raccourci mais c'est un peu un emploi
aidé la différence pour que marc landré
va nous expliquer bien incapable n'ont
pas pensé rc2 structurellement depuis
les tuques
chaque ministre chaque exécutif doit
avoir son dispositif d'emplois aidés
alors après destinée la aux jeunes là au
public en difficulté
là au moins de 26 ans la aux seniors il
y avait eu un plan en 2008 2000 2009 par
laurent wauquiez qui était pour ceux qui
sol et les chômeurs de longue durée qui
était vieux et qui les bascules et non
plus dans la bascule et de
l'indemnisation chômage au rsa donc on
arrive à faire des choses très très très
ciblée alors oui ce sont ni plus ni
moins que des emplois aidés qui vont
donner lieu à un effet d'aubaine
extraordinaire parce que des jeunes oui
un fort taux de chômage c'est vrai dans
ces quartiers là mais aussi beaucoup de
jeunes qui viennent de ces quartiers et
qui sont embauchés dans une entreprise
traditionnelle donc ces jeunes là qui
sont embauchés en autriche traditionnel
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
eh bien ils vont recevoir un chèque
lettres 7500 euros en cdi et sinon enfin
de 15000 euros en cdi et de ses landes
500 sur trois ans et prenez mcdo par
exemple 5000 euros prenez mcdo mcdo qui
va dans l'est dans les lieux ils font
comme emmanuel macron ils vont là où ça
castagne là où ils vont in situ qu'ils
embauchent qui mcdo dans ces quartiers
là ils ont tous des jeunes des quartiers
donc ça veut dire que d'israël et de
toute façon mais là ils vont bénéficier
pour chaque embauche d'un chèque de
15000 euros
donc il l'effet d'aubaine et on mesure
d'ailleurs les effets d'aubaine donc
généralement entre 90 et 95% sur ce type
d'emploi donc voilà il n'y a pas de
raison que ça soit différent et donc ça
aura les mêmes effets ça pourrait coûter
très cher ceci dit pour l'instant on est
sur une expérimentation sur deux ans qui
va concerner 20 mille personnes sur cinq
quartiers donc on a le temps de revenir
en arrière
on l'annoncé aujourd'hui sauf que ça a
été voté la semaine dernière donc c'est
une nouveauté génial aujourd'hui mais
c'est amendement parlementaire depuis la
semaine dernière qui a été votée sur le
volume financier le monde le nombre de
personnes
vous parliez de castagne en a une qui
cas stan bien c'est martine aubry
martine aubry maire de lille qui n'est
pas franchement convaincus par le plan
macro on va l'écouter
moi je suis totalement sceptique parce
que je pense réellement que ce n'est pas
une politique qui va mener vers la
croissance et vers l'emploi
je pense est une politique qui est
souvent brutale par exemple les mesures
sur le logement social
on n'a pas eu le temps de parler le dsf
mais quand on enlève autant sur le
logement social pour baisser de 4
milliard liée sf on peut se demander où
est l'intérêt économique
où est la modernité si ce n'est le
clientélisme dont il nous parle quand il
parle des élus locaux on l'a dit là on
revient sur la politique là elle fait de
la politique martine aubry et c'est la
jambe gauche de manière festive mais
lyon mais je retiens le dernier mot dans
son intervention que vous avez
sélectionné ces élus locaux parce que je
pense que là il ya un sujet c'est à dire
qu'effectivement dans la mise en oeuvre
de ce plan qu'elle qu'en soit la nature
la dimension et ses îles il ne peut
fonctionner en tout état de cause que si
ça interface correctement avec les élus
locaux or il ya un certain nombre de
contentieux aujourd'hui ya les élus
locaux apl justement emplois aidés donc
est ce que ça peut se mettre en
mécanique avec les élus locaux c'est là
où il peut y avoir un changement c'est
trop peu trop peut-être 60 minutes si
c'est pas ça qui va renverser la vapeur
par rapport aux élus locaux
malheureusement le coup de main à
jean-louis borloo qui a annoncé qu'il
allait rejoindre et avec ses à porter
tout seul ça forçait m'élève macron pour
la mise en oeuvre de ce plan
je pense que le coup de pouce peut être
elle si on lui fait faire autre chose
que
pendant si on se concentre sur
l'urbanisme et l'organisation
parce que c'est ça le truc intéressant
devant lui c'est construire et rénover
les rénover physiquement ces quartiers
il a été effectivement à l'origine du
plan d'il ya plus de dix ans ou entamer
souffre raffarin continuer sous villepin
c'était un grenelle à l'époque avec un
grand new deal est effectivement la
création de la rue avec des milliards
déversés pour refaire les barres
d'immeubles sahut en effet on dit
toujours vrai faux que valenciennes ça a
marché à l'ancienne ça marchait aussi
ailleurs dans tout les quartiers
aujourd'hui la physionomie de des
quartiers n'est plus la même le
physiquement les quartiers ne ressemble
plus la même chose et on le voit il
suffit de passer en voiture ou en tram
ou métro et robert lang ou en bus dans
ces quartiers ils n'ont plus le même
visage aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'ils
avaient il ya 10 15 ans et c'est vrai
que mais c'est pas pour autant que que
l'insécurité reculé c'est pas pour
autant que l'emploi s'y est développée
on a simplement mis des fleurs là où il
y avait du béton après ça change pas
fondamentalement la donne d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant parce que moi j'avais
participé l'année dernière aux journées
du non renouvellement urbain qui était
organisé par l'anru et on avait
interrogé les habitants de ces quartiers
qui avait bénéficié justement
du plan et c'est exactement ce qu'ils me
disaient ils ont perçu vraiment les
améliorations de façon notable en terme
de confort de vie cadre de vie mais il
pointait du doigt effectivement de deux
sujets phares pour l'avenir qui était
sentiment de sécurité et l'emploi
et pour revenir jusqu'à sur ce qui a été
dit là où les français par le sentiment
qu'on est un peu justement dans du
saupoudrage et un énième plan c les
contradictions qui peut être perçu je
ressens je rejoins marc four je pense
que sur la question de l'emploi francs
en poids aidez moi je suis la place des
français l opinion j'ai l'impression
qu'on a détricoté quelque chose pour
faire un effet d'annoncé en face à la
manière des appels sur les apn ce que
disent aujourd'hui les bailleurs sociaux
c'est que en devant compenser
la baisse des appels dans les logements
sociaux et on va complètement entravé
leur capacité d'investissement de
construction des logements et donc du
coup tout ça peut paraître un peu
contradictoire et comme étant plutôt de
la communication et de la l'opportunisme
plutôt qu'un vrai une vraie politique
menée est pensé pour les quartiers pour
la ville on parlait de jean louis borloo
le technicien sait aussi il ramène du
monde en termes politiques borloo
derrière imed ben il a une image qui est
très positive dans l'opinion il est
resté vous savez c'est assez étonnant
libolo c'est un des rares hommes
politiques je dis aux hommes politiques
qui dans la rue et saluer suscite
l'empathie la sympathie redemande de ses
nouvelles et c'est donc c'est ça fait
curieux ils sont pas très nombreux à
pouvoir créer ce sentiment là
spontanément et donc il apporte
peut-être une dimension qui mène voilà
avec cette espèce de yoni de chaleur de
bonhomie et puis d'investissement
personnel de conviction aussi les y
voilà il est puisqu'il a fait réellement
donc je pensais plutôt très bien ça mais
c'est fini par s'additionner à peu ces
gens qui rejoignent une façon d'une
autre qui doit pas moi je vais bien j'ai
apporté mon mama main à la pâte non ça
finit par faire si vous avez raison je
l'aï l'addition qu'il est en train de
s'orienter en train de se passer quelque
chose d'une autre faction dans la
composition politique se poursuit
dans un sens ce qui est passionnant
observé très impressionnant parce que
c'est peut-être sans retour c'est en
train de se faire là et sarko on figure
très très largement le système politique
français
il est fait il se rapprocher oui on se
pressait dans l'autre de toilette de la
présidentielle et finalement rival
aurait fait garder lui dévoile à aikido
final ça s'est pas fait c'était beau
c'est le sens de l'histoire comme ça ça
se passe il a signé un axe juppé tout ça
est ce assez cohérent dans la chapelle
alors la bourde la bourde fiscal vous
l'attendez marc landré je crois le
rapport de l'inspection générale des
finances sur la taxe des dividendes est
implacable enfin façon de parler car et
on y apprend que la bourde serait dû à
un concours de circonstances a des
responsabilités plus réelle je cite
c'est ce qu'on appelle noyer le poisson
aucun nom n'est cité et surtout pas
celui d' emmanuel macron marc landré
petite question plus de forme
on sait que le rapport est un peu
réécrivent est rendue vendredi dernier
et puis finalement il a fallu attendre
d'hier a prévenu le week end il s'est
passé quoi c'est au mali c est mon alice
et on enlevait je pense qu'on a enlevé
les coquilles ce qui est de dire que oui
bah c est donc pour rendre une copie
propre je pense qu'elle a été à
l'interdît police est officiellement ce
qui nous a été dit quand on s'est
renseigné pour savoir quand est ce qu
effectivement on aurait ce rapport pour
pouvoir le lire et l'analyser c'était
que marie-christine lepetit donc la chef
de service de li gf c'est le même qui a
écrit le rapport donc si vous dire qu'il
la sphère est importante
avec mettez plus de temps à mettre le
point final parce qu'elle n'avait plus
mis plus de monde que prévu et que
finalement les discussions avaient été
plus importante que ce qu'elle pensait
donc du coup il ça prenait plus de temps
pour ça c'est pour la version officielle
la version la vraie version c'est que
[Musique]
j'allais dire jean louis borloo bruno le
maire a fait une petite bourde en en
annonçant ce délit j'entends cette
septième édition cd il l'a fait dans le
figaro il l'a dit avec des mots qui
était très très fort en parlant d'un
machisme de l'équipe précédente
en parlant de scandale d'état jerry
fallait derrière quand même bien il
fallait il fallait il fallait alimenter
le problème c'est que de fait
ben l'amateurisme de l'équipe précédente
elle inclut le président de la
république
donc il fallait trouver les mots il
fallait trouver des expressions il
fallait trouver je pense le tact pour
savoir l'an dégagements ce qu'il fait
rêve un peu quand on lit ou n'est pas le
celui d'un expert mai 2011 au moment où
ils ont dans ce sens et qu'il ya
vraiment deux périodes dans cette
histoire du fiasco de la taxe il yal en
un qui est de 2012 à 2015 et laon 2
après 2015 et après il faut savoir où
était emmanuel macron dans le ces deux
périodes la première période de la
constitution de cette taxe il n'y a pas
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on lit dans le
dans le rapport doligé est fait c'est ce
qui ressort des gens que nous on a pu
aussi interrogé sur la question il n'y a
pas de notes d'administration officielle
disant que cette taxe va dans le mur
constitutionnellement il ya le
dentifrice du doute qui pouvait très
bien pas savoir ils pouvaient ne passera
en tout cas
en tout cas c'est à dire que
l'information ne lui est pas remonté
comme il n'y avait pas de problème a
priori ça a été géré au niveau des
cabinets des ministres ce n'est pas
remonté jusqu'à l'elysée pour trancher
le fait de savoir s'il fallait faire
cette taxe ou non puisque en amont il
n'y avait pas de problème juridique
a priori la question est différente sur
poste 2015 poste 2015
on a le revirement de jurisprudence
européenne on a christian eckert qui lui
même dit dans lors d'une audition au
sénat
attention un problème juridique et là
rien n'est fait lorsque nous
l'expliquent et le rapport et les gens
notamment moi je vais parler pas plus
tard que la semaine hier avec 1
ministres concernés c'est simple nous on
a reçu des notes de l'administration qui
me disait de ne pas bouger
oui un problème juridique oui elle a un
problème financier
oui la france serait condamné à
rembourser les contentieux sauf que
comme il y avait le contentieux qui
était en train d'être discutés auprès de
la cour de justice des communautés
européennes il fallait pas qu'on remette
dix balles dans la machine lors danival
ordonne qu'on leur donne matière à
mithaq à nous condamner encore plus je
dirais en plus et dernièrement je dirais
que tout le monde s'attendait à une
censure du conseil constitutionnel
infiné mais une sangsue à partielle ou
totale et en plus olivier duhamel qui
souvent dans cette émission le rappeler
c'était l'idée que les intérêts
moratoires été alourdi la facture
fortement oblige à payer en une seule
fois et non pas en disant décalé comme
avant qu'on poursuive
on écoute juste guillaume pelletier sur
ce point guillaume pelletier qui est
député l ère du loir-et-cher fondateur
de la transe forte
il était ce matin sur france info il
s'en prend aux technocrates emmanuel
macron aurait beaucoup à gagner à sortir
d'un triptyque infernal bruxelles bercy
l'ena c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui la
france du dirigeant à tokyo aujourd'hui
les dirigeants français depuis trop
longtemps à l'instar d' emmanuel macron
sont soumis à ce trio c'est à dire les
technocrates de bruxelles qui a qui
décide à la place des peuples bercy les
vieux fermiers généraux qui imposent
leurs politiques publiques
quant à l'ena cette hyper administration
qui empêche les créations et toute la
france des provinces de se lever
jean-marc juste pour rebondir sur ce
quotidien réflexe de corps quand même on
dit l'inspection générale des finances à
maquereau inspecteur des finances
demande d'énergie enfin moi je pense que
c'est une question légitime absolument
oui d'ailleurs madame le petit dans le
préambule de ce rapport écrit elle même
je dis ça tu démarres mais en gros j'ai
participé moi même à la genèse de ce
projet la fameuse taxe est donc quelque
part bon ben il faut que vous lisiez ce
qui va suivre comme écrit par quelqu'un
qui d'une façon elle ne dit pas comme ça
mais est juge et partie
c'est vraiment tout essayé un wc
reviennent de lit j'ai imaginé en
prenant par exemple imaginons que il ya
une enquête sur le fair play financier
au paris saint-germain puisqu'on va
parler le football vous savez à marx est
impatient et que on confie l'enquète
soit fair play financier du paris saint
germain au ministre des finances du
qatar qu'est ce qui va vous dire mille
des finances du qatar que tout va bien
au paris saint germain mais c'est un peu
pareil c'est un peu pareil c'est à dire
que on confie réflexion générale des
finances c'est à dire quand même un
accord qui est un corps d'élite ou qui
se voit en tout cas comme l'élite ya 200
personnes dans aujourd'hui ce sont les
hauts fonctionnaires qui rédige aussi
qui prépare en tout cas ces textes
fiscaux
on leur dit de juger le travail des
camarades quoi donc c'est pas il y à il
ya en tout cas il peut y avoir en tout
cas matière à s'interroger tomic
pour moi il ya évidemment un problème
mais pas du tout dans les termes et donc
c'est par exemple banquiers oui ça tout
ça c'est pas une source interne leur ex
colisée bruxelles bercy lennar même
combat par ailleurs ces idées dans sa
dérive ultra-libérale je vous reprends
ses mots des médias le maquereau sais
pas s'il ya trop de fonctionnaires au
passé trop de régulation passé à l'impôt
perdu
non c'est pas en ces termes la série
c'est caricatural mais par contre ce qui
est problématique c'est pas la première
fois que ça se produit c'est une
irresponsabilité de fêtes de l'état je
signale juste pour mémoire parce que
c'est un autre exemple qui va faire des
portiques qui tout de même a été
extraordinairement coûteuse
enfin si en plusieurs milliards sans
qu'on sache vraiment aujourd'hui que ce
qui s'est passé au fond ou qui a été
responsable de cette des espèces de
violences commises qui a un côté
apprentis sorciers je pose aussi la
question à marc à bercy et celle des
fiscalistes où on a l'impression qu'il
veut 10 ou même dans le rapport on sait
plus très bien ce qu'on fait ou on va ce
qu'on a le droit de faire ou pas vous
prenez la taxe aux dividendes à 3% elle
a été décidée dans l'urgence en juillet
2012 dont le projet de loi de finances
rectificative
juste après l'arrivée de françois
hollande parce que son ennemi étant la
finance il fallait taxer la finance et
surtout il fallait trouver 2 milliards
de recettes par an pour prier quand ans
sur les opcvm précédent donc oui ça a
été monté à l'urgence oui ça a été fait
et si vous reprenez bien d'ailleurs le
nombre de 2-2 projets fiscaux de loi de
dispositifs fiscaux qui ont été
invalidés par le conseil constitutionnel
à commencer par la taxe à 75% ses deux
revenus supérieurs à un million d'euros
ces légions au point que le conseil
constitutionnel est selon des experts
disent qu'aujourd'hui le premier garant
de l'étude de la dérive au delà de 2 202
de l'imagination sans limite des techno
de bercy à la création fiscal c'est le
conseil constitutionnel qui le premier
dit stop
là c'est pas possible c'est
anticonstitutionnel c'est le problème
c'est que sur cette taxe est précisément
le conseil d'état en 2012 a été consulté
et n'a pas vu la faille
donc ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas qu'à
bercy et que qui est qui et qui peut y
avoir un problème
il ya aussi parmi nos juristes
soi-disant les meilleurs experts de
l'afld de la bonne odeur de la nation
que ça pêche aussi l'addition quand même
10 milliards d'euros le chiffre est
frappant
là aussi ça exaspère pas un peu les
français de se dire il y en a qui disent
je caricature mais j'ai fait une
connerie c'est ça coûte 10 milliards oui
mais surtout dans ce contexte
effectivement on a l'impression avec
notamment un rapport qui dira ça
concours de circonstances on n'a pas
fait exprès en substance cela pointe aux
yeux des français une certaine
incompétence et ça vient nourrir les
responsabilités farah était bien nourrir
7 sentiment de défiance envers les
institutions politiques notamment l'état
le gouvernement
et puis pour redire ce que disait marc
landré monde a déjà eu l'occasion
d'évoquer dans cette émission
ça montre aussi parfois l'espèce de gap
qui peut y avoir entre la politique
politicienne et les annonces qu'on peut
faire au cours d'une campagne et la
réalité de la mise en oeuvre des
politiques publiques on voit que voilà
vous vous disiez françois hollande est
élu il faut vite mettre en place une
taxe en sans se poser la question de sa
recevabilité d'un point de vue juridique
sa faisabilité et là ou encore ça vient
nourrir à mon sens le sentiment d'une
certaine jeunesse et de l'incompétence
dans tout cas de la défiance des
français qui effectue globalement marée
peuvent se dire à quoi ça sert tout tous
ces fonctionnaires tous ces acteurs pour
qu'on en arrive là ça va aussi peut-être
qu elle exaspérée et c'est là où ça
devient aussi une forte de café en bout
de chaîne c'est que qui va payer en
partie la facture
ah oui c'est par exemple vous et moi sur
votre peut-être sur votre facture de
mutuelle enfin sur votre contrat de
mutuelle parce que c'est ce que
commencent à nous dire les mutuelles
c'est à dire que comme elles vont être
taxés pour compenser fameux elles vont
peut-être augmenter leurs tarifs
et du coup c'est vous c'est moi qui à
notre échelle allons payer quand même la
facture donc là peut-être que les
français ça va les exaspérer un peu oui
tout autre sujet que vous propose
d'aborder maintenant c'est celui de
cette barbie une barbie voilées alors ça
fait belle lurette que barbie n'a plus
les cheveux blonds et les yeux bleus
c'est tant mieux
la pouf les a même pris quelques kilos
ces dernières années mais la nouveauté
elle est voilée elle est mis sur le
marché son fabricant
géant américain mattel nous explique que
c'est en l'honneur d'une escrimeuse
américaine qui est devenu en 2016 la
première sportive américaine voilée à
participer aux jeux olympiques
ça vous choque adélaïde zulfikarpasic je
faire un tour de table mais en un mot
oui non la barbie voile et je dirais oui
parce qu'on a eu c'est plus du marketing
que une conviction je remarque c'est
évidemment du marketing matin ne va pas
bien donc il cherche sûrement pas hier
écrit avec d'autres produits
et le problème c'est comme si comme
souvent mais ce n'est pas la première
fois le marketing légitime une forme
d'idéologie derrière enfin ça donne une
forme de poids mais c'est pas la
première fois je veux dire vous demander
pardon de le dire mais enfin les pubs
pour les voitures et les parfums ou le
corps de la femme et des idées il sa
légitime aussi une forme de logique
voilà plus de dix essais pas un serment
mieux il a la voiture il aura la fin
mais probablement ça veut dire côté on a
des discours sur les jouets qu'il faut
cesser de genre et puis on voit surgir
un jouet voile et donc je trouve que
l'on la des mondes de démo
d'argumentation et de discussion ils ont
complètement désarticulé ça va faire
beaucoup de ça avec effectivement une
forme d'hypocrisie
peut-être le dire ce parce que mme at
elle dit mais c'est une forme
d'émancipation puisque cette sportive
à participer aux jo et voilà et donc
formidable alors juste accueillir
marouane qui nous a rejoint mais a
laissé tout ça ne choque pas à partir du
moment où le pouls le port du voile est
autorisé
je vois pas pourquoi on interdirait où
on serait choqué du fait qu'une poupée
barbie sa peine il appelle télévision
commerciale je suis d'accord
l'argumentation est à dire le fait de le
faire il faut la suivait quand ça va ce
de parler de jouer mon genre eh oui
alors parce qu'on s'y perd on sait plus
ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il faut faire
déjouer jean ray ou bien moi je me
rappelle que ma fille était sais pas si
longtemps que ça l'est encore petite île
il fallait acheter des peignoirs le
élite poupée n'est pas que blanche qui a
aussi des zones d'un enfant noir dont
voici le var donc si on sait qu'une
poupée noire ce que ça très bien je vois
pourquoi on achèterait pas une poupée
alors qui va nous dire tout le bien ou
le mal que pensent les réseaux sociaux
de cette barbie voilée et du voile en
général parce que le sujet récurrent
c'est ça comme vous en doutez le voile
c'est un sujet prête à polémique sur les
réseaux sociaux est donc aujourd'hui
c'était l'un des sujets les plus
commentés barbie sur twitter ce matin
quand je suis arrivé j'ai vu hashtag
barbie j'ai pas très bien compris
pourquoi polémique ou soutien pour la
nouvelle pub poupée de mattel ce n'est
pas la provoc le diable le voile en
arabe fait réagir aujourd'hui c'est la
comète commercialisation de cette poupée
qui représentent-ils l'escrimeuse très
connu aux états unis imtiaz mohammad
c'est la première athlète voilée à
représenter des états unis dans une
compétition sportive internationale
alors oui j'avais jusqu'au choc expliqué
marc landré c'est un voile qui ne couvre
que les cheveux différent du niqab et de
la burqa pour les internautes j'explique
dire la différence est donc crucial
romaine elle est très connue parce
qu'elle a remporté notamment la médaille
de bronze par équipes aux championnats
du monde de 2011 2012 2013 bref les très
connus et aujourd'hui elle s'en est
réjoui sur instagram de cette poupée
elle a écrit je suis fier de savoir que
les petites filles partout peuvent
maintenant jouer avec une barbie qui
choisit de porter le hijab
c'est un rêve d'enfance devenu réalité
et elle ne sera dispo qu'en 2018 tant
pis pour eux
si ces remarques si c'est un coup de
marketing je sais pas vraiment parce que
mattel en fait c'est la deuxième année
consécutive qu'ils vainquent el arbi la
marche si je sais pas si ça marche plus
mais en tout cas c'est la deuxième année
qu'il font une poupée qui représente une
sportive
c'est pas la première fois parfois parce
que la dernière il y avait l'athlète
gymnastes afro américaine gabrielle
douglas c'est la première femme noire à
avoir remporté la médaille d'or par
équipes et en individuel aux jeux
olympiques de 2012 et en dehors de
mattel on a eu d'autres polémiques on a
eu aussi nike qui il ya quelques mois en
empruntant si je me trompe pas avait
créé un hijab pour les sportives
c'était sont dues par l'athlète manuel
rostom et elle est le slogan de la pub
c'était que vente il dira donc il
fallait déjà qu'ils allaient avoir une
polémique et manel rostom disait
justement cette coach connu il ne s'agit
pas seulement de faire un produit
disponible pour les musulmanes et les
arabes mais aussi de donner une chance à
ces femmes qui étaient en train
d'abandonner l'idée de porter le voile
pour participer pour participer aux
compétitions
parce qu'en fait le voile ça fait des
années qu'il a du mal à entrer dans les
moeurs du sport il ya encore de nombreux
sports où il n'est pas possible de le
porter et il a fallu attendre 2014 pour
que la fifa l'autorisent par exemple en
printemps dernier autre polémique gap
avait présentés en vitrine des images de
sa nouvelle collection avec notamment
une femme qui portait le voile
pourtant dans sa collection n'y avait
pas de voile il voulait juste montrer la
diversité des femmes qui pouvaient
porter le voile et gap avait expliqué ne
pas vendre de hijab mais que sa
collection s'adressait à tout le monde
comme il y avait également bénéteau
quelques années avant en 2016
je m'arrête pas
on avait uniqlo qui commercialisait des
voiles et des tuniques inspirés de la
mode musulmane dans quelques pays et sur
son site internet donc là pour le coup
s'était étendue et c'était après les
états unis et l'asie et y'avait londres
qui accueillait les jeunes uniqlo donc à
rosny qu il y avait d'autres marques qui
avait déjà fait la même chose sauf que
d'habitude c'était souvent pendant la
période du ramadan ou restera au pays
musulmans donc c'est pour ça que ça
avait choqué et c'est un coup marketing
comme tu l'as dit tout à l'heure
intervient au moment où wall street
journal a rapporté que le rival hasbro
envisage de racheter mattel et hasbro
qui possède monopoly marc landré je suis
heureux de vous dire que huguette
blizzard est d'accord avec vous seagate
nous dit que pourquoi pas une poupée
voile et personnellement je trouve ça
normal les voiles et vous dites ont
aussi le droit d'exister alors
exactement il a faim et la fifa l'a
autorisé en 2014 leur grade mais il y
avait eu on le rappeler en préparant les
missions une histoire dans le c'était
dans quel sport un sport collectif où le
voile avait été interdit parce que pour
des motifs de sécurité
c'était du hand non c'était du bonbon
il ya aussi cette affaire on l'avait
souligné en son temps de catalogues ikea
qui avait gommé les femmes catalogue
quand il était destiné ou à l'arabie
saoudite ou aux populations dites ultra
orthodoxes en israël dont il y avait les
deux bouts d'eux de la bon tout ça c'est
du ce et du marketing et du spur oui
c'est du marketing puis encore faut-il
mettre des mots là où ils sont appelés à
faire un choix et puis l'assumé voilà au
moins autant ça me choque pas qu'on
fasse une poupée voilée du moment que
c'est pas du prosélytisme pro niqab et
que ont ils fassent pas faire les
prières de rue à clichy en l'occurrence
venir après regardez cette photo la voix
les très belles je veux dire jeudi il ya
70 at war c'est pas la voiture il y
avait aussi un mouvement de boycott qui
n'a pas dû prospérer quand au moment
clo h&m et autres avaient commencé à
mettre des mourres cas dans leur
catalogue en occident oui attaqués très
loin
non il ya contraire vous avez une boîte
comme 0 acquis au fil de fer donc ce
sont des stratégies marketing encore
faut-il qu'elle soit assumée comme telle
voilà en tout cas ça marche en termes de
publicité je veux dire voilà voilà
toute la presse a parlé de barbie toute
la journée voilà alors je sais que vous
brûlez d'impatience ne parlait un peu de
foot après barbie faut-il pleurer
l'absence de l'italie au prochain
mondial marc landré vous pleurez même
allure plus fluide que nadal ait déclaré
forfait au masters
ah non mais non verrouillée pato la bbc
c'est marc savard et franchement
franchement ce n'est que du sport ce
n'est que du foot voilà ils ont permis
tant qui pour eux ils seront pas au
mondial c'est triste pour les italiens
je sais qu'ils vont avoir du mal à s'en
remettre mais il me semble que la france
n'ait pas été mondial de 96 on en est où
94 on n'est pas morts on avait même
gagné 198 jean-marc il se trouve que ce
matin eric cantona était une évaluation
sommaire et il a parlé d'un tout petit
peu en fin d'interview avec la salle à
mes deux de cette élimination inattendue
de l'italie et pour observer une chose
et je trouve ça assez assez juste une
disait il ya quelque chose de triste
vraiment là dedans c'est cdj luigi
bouffonne phone cardiaque le gardien
quand même extraordinaire gardien
italien qui en est je crois sans 75
sélections d'imaginer 176 m et 6e sur
l'été sur ses sixièmes mondiaux et donc
mais au lieu de sortir sur un mondial
il sort sur ce piteux match nul face au
suédois et c'est vrai que c'est une
femme cadre il s'est quand même une
figure de pour les gens qui aiment le
football bouffonne c'est une figure en
plus c'est une figure enfin ascétique
c'est quelqu'un de voilà qu'il ya des
valeurs c'est pas juste là footeux quoi
voyez c'est quelqu'un de ce quelqu'un de
bien comme on dit quoi bouffer donc
c'est vrai que c'est une sortie de
carrière pour pour ce pour cette figure
du sport qui est un peu un peu tristoune
va s'émouvoir d'ailleurs c'est qu'il a
dit que le temps file et vite
en commentant le fait qu'il fallait
qu'il s'arrête
c'est marrant parce qu'il a fait quand
même une carrière extraordinaire mal il
va dilatoire file vite resterez ça assez
bon finalement c'est triste pour les
italiens parce que le rapport au foot
est quand même centrale
et c'est un pays qui va pas très bien
moi je trouve l'italie entre notre
réseau et donc je sais pas ça qui pense
que ça fait partie des choses qui
peuvent justement aider à une nation et
c'est au foot et les italiens moment des
élections en mars qui sont un peu
compliquées ce sera davantage a délégué
un peu la même chose pour ne pas parler
de foot mais j'allais dire
qu'effectivement pour les italiens c'est
sept fondateurs pour eux et quand on
voit effectivement des indicateurs comme
ceux de l'eurobaromètre on voit que les
italiens n'ont pas le moral et qui ne se
sont pas vraiment inclut notamment par
rapport à la question européenne
ils sont très critiques par rapport à
l'euro près qu'ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir été un peu abandonné que la
crise des migrants et je pense que tout
ça et va pas contribuer à un sentiment
un peu de fédérateur fédérateur et puis
d'inclusion dans un mouvement collectif
donc c'est assez dommage
au delà du foot juste fait un petit
événement quand même que
les italiens puisque nous la mesure est
aussi dans l'étude qu'on a réalisé dans
26 pays
il rapporte des italiens la démocratie à
la l'europe pardon c'est une nouveauté
il était parmi les plus là ça s'est
vraiment c'est casser ça c'est un petit
événement enfin la même un événement
considérable
oui oui bien sûr sûr mais c'est quand
même quelque chose il faut prendre en
compte et oui effectivement la presse
italienne ce matin titrait tout cas pour
la gazzetta dello sporte c'est
l'apocalypse on est hors du mondial il
n'y aura pas deux ans 88 n'y aura pas de
nuit magique
l'italie ne participera pas ne
participera pas au mondial que ce
n'était pas arrivé depuis 50 8 l'italie
lors du mondial fin je vous passe les
laits les titres de la presse mais
c'était effectivement transnationales on
va pas jouer les prolongations parce que
c'est la fin de cette émission mais je
vous propose de ne pas quitter figaro
life avec un nouveau numéro de concert
de conversation tout de suite
conversation entre le les pionniers de
l'écologie les céistes pierre rabhi et
notre journaliste marie laëtitia
bonavita puis arabi qui n'est pas tout à
fait d'accord avec l'appel des 15000
scientifique sur le climat merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre et à demain
pour un prochain point de vue
[Musique]